>> Alright, let's do another quiz. That previous example that
we looked at of intervals, was nice and pedagogical, and reasonable
to think about, but we actually hadn't really talked about any
learning algorithms that used intervals. On the other hand, linear separators
are a very big deal in machine learning. So, it's,
it's very worthwhile, and it turns out to be not too
bad to work out what the vc dimension is for linear
separators. So, let's say that we're in two dimensional space, and
so our hypotheses have the form that you've got
a parameter, a weight parameter, w. And were going to just
take that weight parameter, take the dot product with whatever
the input is, and see whether its greater than or
equal to some value, theta. And if it is,
then we say that's a positive example, and if not
it's a negative example, and geometrically that just means that
we've, we end up specifying a line, and everything on
one side of the line is going to be positive, and
everything on the other side of the line's going to be negative.
>> Got it. That makes sense. So what's the vc
dimension? Oh, they're going to have to tell us. I like that.
>> Alright.
>> Go.